how much mileage can you get out of two
dumb teens making crude jokes about
anything and everything the answer is
apparently quite a bit who are you fart
knockers amusing yes humorous yes
satirical comment on the time yeah
the butthead soared to the stratosphere
of pop culture in the 1990s people tuned
in from all over to watch the two get in
trouble between sessions of sitting on
the couch watching music videos their
escapades culminated in the 1996 film
beavis and butthead do america after
which they entered a long hibernation
with a few sporadic returns now they're
back once again with a new film coming
straight to paramount plus beavis and
butthead do the universe that's right
the kids aren't just traveling across
the united states for their latest
adventure they're going into the
furthest reaches of space and if the
trailer is any indication they'll
provide ample commentary on the current
state of the world it's understandable
that fans would be wary of such a
project can beavis and butthead survive
and thrive in modern times but according
to critics these spheres are unfounded
in fact beavis and butthead do the
universe may just be one of the best
reviewed films of the year as it scored
an astonishing rating on rotten tomatoes
we're finally gonna score
after the first wave of reviews for the
movie hit rotten tomatoes the film held
a stunning score of 100 the only thing
that would have been better is if the
critics rating was at 69. and while it's
been a while since we've seen the two
jokesters it seems that they haven't
missed a step during that long time away
critics praised the film for its humor
and social commentary a doubt of the
guardian wrote thankfully the time away
hasn't diminished the smart dumb comedic
value of their personas watching this
latest revival fans will probably match
them chuckle for chuckle it seems as
though anyone who was a fan of the
stupidity of the characters throughout
their mtv series and their previous
feature length project is in for much of
the same which is precisely what makes
do the universe such a delight the
characters may not change but their
surroundings do allowing the duo to
offer their signature brand of humor in
an entirely new environment danielle
ryan of slash film had this to say fans
nostalgic for cornholio double entendres
and all of the
are sure to be overjoyed there's a lot
of comedy to be mined simply in watching
two dudes from 1998 try to make sense of
2022 and their idiocy only makes it
funnier it's much of the same with
beavis and butthead and that's exactly
what critics like about it it's another
asinine romp that's coming at the
perfect time to shine a light on modern
culture in a way only these two could
provide
this changes everything
the legacy sequel has become all the
rage as of late we've already seen how
successful this can be this summer with
the insane popularity of top gun
maverick and while it seems like nothing
could unseat that picture as the legacy
sequel of the summer beavis and butthead
do the universe certainly gives it a run
for its money handily taking the second
place spot plenty of outlets were quick
to mention top gun maverick in their
reviews for the latest beavis and
butthead outing and while the two films
couldn't be more different they share a
desire to bring the past to the modern
day owen gliberman of variety stated i'm
not sure that the world was clamoring
for another beavis and butthead movie
and this one isn't exactly the top gun
maverick of bnb head sequels it is
however a shaggy snark infused lark
that's likable enough to get by kate
erbland of indiewire also couldn't help
but include a shout out to top gun
maverick explaining nothing will top top
gun maverick this summer in its profound
ability to please a rabid fan base but
second place now has a strong contender
with beavis and butthead do the universe
what's next for the duo who can't help
but laugh at every sexual reference it's
a big universe out there hopefully it's
not the last time we've seen them
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]